after the amazing start yesterday we
have more
good morning
unfortunately wanted to hear about this
to talk about it
great uh let's see uh yeah okay it
sounds like it sounds like the audio is
working hopefully everyone can hear me
I'll go ahead and dive in yeah so this
is a talk about what I'm calling
interactive decision making you know
kind of in line with the theme of the
workshop but let me just make sure we're
on the same page but what I mean by this
right so when I say interactive decision
making I'm thinking about problems where
we're you know interacting with an
unknown environment you know and trying
to make decisions on the fly like you
know what signal do I send to my robots
actuator or you know what treatment do I
give to a patient
um and I'm really thinking about
problems where we want to do this in a
like data driven fashion like we want to
learn to model the environment better
and better so that we can improve our
decisions as we go
so you know interactive decision making
this is a very broad problem you know
there's all sorts of different ways you
can try to like formulate and attack
this depending on the problem domain
right we have these formulations like
contextual Bandits they're widely used
in like online recommendation we have
these more General formulations like
reinforcement learning and control that
then applied throughout Robotics and
there are all sorts of like you know
very other interesting formulations that
we see across like operations research
and let's say like personalized medicine
and so you know the question we're going
to try to explore in this talk is you
know given that we have all these
different ways of you know formulating
and trying to solve the interactive
decision-making problem
can we get something like a unified
approach to you know designing
algorithms and understanding sample
complexity and like statistical
considerations you know this way we
don't have to necessarily like start
from scratch every time we're faced with
a new problem domain
and so you know with that in mind the
game plan is going to be so I'll start
by formally introducing
you know the interactive decision making
problem and kind of highlighting some
challenges then we can introduce a new
way of trying to solve this we'll see
how this uh you know leads to kind of
new algorithms and Sample complexity
guarantees through a bunch of
illustrative examples
so let me let's let's just go ahead and
dive in
okay so for this talk because I want to
be able to kind of you know look at many
different decision making problems it'll
be helpful to adopt a kind of General
language for talking about these
decision making problems which we call
you know decision making with structured
observations and again this is really
just like a simple kind of like let's
say like unified language
so the way this is going to work is
we're going to play for capital T rounds
we're at each round Little T we're first
going to select a decision Pi T so big
Pi here is our like decision space and
then based on this decision we're going
to uh get some kind of reward
and we're also going to see some kind of
auxiliary observation and our our goal
is just to learn to maximize this reward
as we go
so if you worked on Bandit problems you
know this should look pretty familiar
um I'll show in a second that kind of
the added generality we have here
actually allows us to Encompass like
things like reinforcement learning but
first I need to get through a few more
details on the setup
so first of all we're going to consider
a stochastic version of this setting so
this means that we have what's called an
underlying uh model M Star which is just
like a conditional distribution over
rewards and observations for the
decision we pick so what we're assuming
is at each time T when we pick our
decision Pi T this reward and this
observation are drawn independently from
this conditional distribution M star of
Pi t
okay so we don't know M star in this
setting this is like this represents the
environment and this is unknown
um but we're going to assume that it
belongs to some known class uh script M
which we're going to call our model
class in this talk
um and this is something you can think
of as you know encoding our prior
knowledge about the problem we're trying
to solve you know in a similar fashion
to how like you know a hypothesis class
would like encode our prior knowledge
about like the prediction tasks we're
trying to solve if we were doing like
supervised learning
okay and The Last Detail to mention here
is we're going to be measuring
performance through regret okay so
regret here is just you know the
difference between the cumulative reward
of the best decision we could have
picked if we knew the underlying model M
Star minus the cumulative reward that
our you know our learning agent actually
achieves
okay and just a note on notation here so
FM of Pi here is just going to denote
like the expected reward of Pi if m is
the underlying model so FM star here is
just like the you know the mean reward
function for M Star okay and Pi star
yeah is just the optimal decision for M
Star
uh yeah question
observation
well I just mean this observation but
let me let's actually go through some
examples to make this more concrete
because this is a great question yeah
so this will be this will Encompass uh
let's say like episodic RL settings it
wouldn't necessarily Encompass a single
trajectory URL settings but yeah let's
I'll go through some examples and you
know we'll make this work with you so
okay you know the most basic example you
can think about here is you know
multi-armed Bandits you know this is
just this classic setting where each
time I pick a discrete decision I get
some reward for this decision I don't
see you know what reward I would have
gotten if I picked a different decision
so in this context we have no
observations besides the rewards
our decision space is just going to be a
finite set one through big eight
um and we're not really going to assume
anything about the rewards so we'll just
say like you know script m is like you
know all possible reward distributions
maybe with some like basic regularity
assumptions like we found it
okay yeah now as I said
okay you know bands is a setting where
we don't typically assume much about the
rewards but it is a setting where we
usually have to have like a small finite
set of actions or Decisions by
incorporating more modeling into your
problem you know you can you can tackle
problems or you have maybe a very large
or continuous set of decisions so linear
Bandits is a setting where let's say our
decision space is some subset of R to
the D but we assume the rewards are
linear which kind of allows you to
extrapolate right and the way you can
Encompass this is just by saying you
know I'm going to restrict script M to
only have models that have you know
linear reward functions right that's
pretty natural
um and of course there's many variants
of this you can look at you know so like
non-parametric Bandits this is a more
General problem where you let's say only
assume the rewards are lip shits again
the way you're going to Encompass this
is just by saying all the models in my
class have lip just Rewards
okay now I I haven't said anything about
observations yet but like Okay so let's
look at the canonical you know setting
we like to think about where these
matter this is going to be episodic
reinforcement learning
so in this setting each model is going
to be a finite Horizon mdp so this is
going to have a state-space script s an
action space script A a probability
transition distribution pm
a reward distribution RM and an initial
State distribution D1 okay
so how is this going to work so the way
an episode and one of these MVPs is
going to work will be that we'll draw
the initial State S1 from this initial
State distribution
then for each step little H equals one
through Big H will pick an action using
some policy that acts on the current
state we'll see a reward based on the
current state in action and we'll see a
you know it will transition to the next
state also based on the current state in
action so how do you view this in our
general framework well that's one
episode but when we when we look at this
in the general framework we're going to
be playing capital T episodes so at each
time step our decision is like what
policy do we play for the episode The
observation here is going to be the
trajectory that this policy gives us so
this like sequence of actions you know
States actions and rewards and you know
the reward function will be aiming to
optimize is just like the cumulative
reward within each episode
okay so uh you know that that's kind of
how that's a simple way of viewing RL in
this framework at least episodic RL and
one thing I want to emphasize here is
you know there's a huge amount of
flexibility in how you do modeling here
so like in this setting your model class
could Bim this is parameterizing you
know like what are the transition
probabilities what are the reward
distributions like what constraints are
you going to put on these things and
there's all sorts of structures that
have been investigated here you know
both like classically and in the last
decade right so you know there's simple
things like finite State sanctions like
tabular MVPs you know there's like
linear dynamical systems but there's
there's a lot out there
okay and so kind of just to get back to
the main point here
um you know the reason we adopted this
this General decision making framework
is just this gives a concise way of
talking about what you can see is like a
pretty broad class of problems
um with many options as far as how you
do modeling
now okay in general
what sort of modeling assumptions like
what model class script M works well for
your problem
this is going to be very domain or like
application specific and so what this is
going to lead us to ask here is you know
can we have something like you know a
unifying notion of problem complexity or
say like statistical complexity
they can you know will capture the
optimal complexity for any problem and
really when I say optimal statistical
complexity here what I mean is like what
is the best regret we can achieve for a
given model class script M and a given
time Horizon t
and kind of the Hope here is you know we
had such a notion of problem complexity
you know maybe this could guide us in
designing algorithms when we encounter
new domains so that we don't necessarily
have to start from scratch like you know
this we could guide us towards like
general algorithmic principles
okay so to motivate our results I want
to try to give a sense for like you know
why this is a challenging problem like
why understanding and you know capturing
the statistical complexity for General
decision making problems is challenging
um and kind of the key Point here is
this is really a combination of like
algorithmic and statistical
considerations these are really like
intertwined
um and the way I want to try to
illustrate this is just by going through
a few examples of different models and
trying to get a sense for well like what
makes these problems easy versus hard
okay so let's start on that
um so okay here's a kind of Bandit type
problem so we only have rewards here
we're only so we only see rewards
there's no other observations our goal
is just to maximize like the underlying
reward function and what we have here is
a model class with like three models M1
M2 and M3 and this plot over here is
just looking at like you know their mean
reward function over the decision space
so
okay so this is
what I'll call like a very easy or
actually trivial decision-making problem
okay so you know if I tell you that the
true model lies in this class script m
in advance well what you can see is like
actually all these models even though
they have different reward functions
they all agree on what the optimal
decision is like they all Peak at the
same place okay so so if someone tells
you in advance you know the underlying
model is in this class well I can just
commit to playing this one point in
advance I don't need to explore or
really like do anything at all like the
algorithm is just play this point you're
done
yeah so that's like kind of the easiest
problem you could hope for let's change
this a little bit okay so now I've moved
these curves around and we've got let's
say three distinct Peaks for these
different models okay and so now this is
a little bit harder like now if I want
to try to maximize the reward function
and I don't know what the underlying
model is I do need to actually like
explore the domain to try to find like
where the peak is and you know in
general you know the number of samples
you need to do this or like the best
regret you can achieve this will scale
with like the number of possible Peaks
or like you know how big your domain or
your decision space is so that's a
slightly harder problem
okay but now I'm going to change this
one more time
okay so this is almost the same we still
have different Peaks but then if we come
over on the right here what's going on
well
I have kind of one very informative
point in the domain right here where I
know that these models all take very
different values
if we look at the reward function Okay
so
now if again if I know in advance that
the true model is in this class what I
can do is just you know play this
decision right here A bunch of times
you know get a good estimate for the
reward at this one point and from this I
can just infer what the underlying curve
is and just hop over to the optimal
solution because I know it's one of
these three models so kind of you know
again just by changing this problem very
slightly I've ended up in a setting
where I don't really need to explore at
all
okay
so to kind of summarize the takeaways
here you know if we want to understand
what is the statistical complexity of
decision making
there's a bunch of considerations we
have to look at right like do we have
many optimal decisions or few optimal
decisions uh you know does a given
decision tell us something just about
the reward at this one point or about
like the whole domain
um and the point I want to emphasize
again is you know this really is like an
algorithmic problem right so like for
the examples we just saw okay they had
different statistical complexity but the
strategies we had to use to achieve this
were very different right it wasn't like
we were just you know fixing some
algorithm like you know ERM or SGD and
just trying to understand like how well
it performs so we change the other like
problem like you might do in say like
supervised or statistical learning
um and just to drill on this even more
so for the examples we just went over we
were really only looking at mean rewards
but these challenges kind of only get
Amplified when we look at more General
problems so like in general even things
like the noise in the reward
distribution can like leak non-trivial
information about the underlying problem
instance and algorithms can exploit this
to do better right like so for example
if you have like a bandit type problem
and I say you know the optimal decision
always has Bernoulli rewards all the
other decisions have gaussian rewards
like that is something that algorithms
can exploit to do better and so any
notion of problem complexity needs to be
able to capture this and of course these
are only Amplified
when we look at these problems like RL
where we have decision spaces and
observation spaces you know that are
very high dimensional
but also very structured
um and so in light of these challenges
I mean I think it's natural to ask you
know is it even reasonable to hope for
some like single notion of problem
complexity that can you know adapt to
all these different settings at least in
a way that's like meaningful or like
let's say like useful or actually
interpretable
um but what I'm going to show now you
know is the answer is in some sense at
least we think yes so we have a kind of
a new notion of statistical complexity
that is uh necessary and sufficient
for low regret in these General decision
making settings
um and Beyond just giving a unified
notion of statistical complexity this is
actually going to come with something
like a unified algorithm design
principle
okay so I'm going to just dive into this
uh so this complexity measure we have we
call this the uh the decision estimation
coefficient
um and I'm displaying this right here um
okay so there's many moving Parts here
but we're gonna like walk through this
step by step and kind of like build some
intuition for what's going on
so so this decision estimation
coefficient or like I'll call it the dec
for short
so this is going to have three
parameters
uh naturally it's going to depend on
this model class script m
it's going to depend on what we'll call
a reference model M Bar in this class
and it's going to depend on a scale
parameter that we call gamma
so let's walk through this
so I'll start by I'll walk through it
once and I'll walk through it again to
make sure everyone's on the same page so
so this is a min max problem this DC is
a min max problem
it's a mint Max problem where uh the Min
player which you can kind of think of as
like representing the learner
is trying to pick a distribution over
decisions
such that for a worst case model in this
class script M selected by the max
player
what they want is to have their sort of
instantaneous regret or like
instantaneous sub-optimality
under this model
uh to be balanced by a notion of like
Information Gain for the decision they
selected okay so here what do I mean by
Information Gain
so what we're looking at here is for the
decision Pi we sample here what is the
distance between the distribution over
rewards and observations under this
reference model
and the the distribution over rewards
and observations under the model
selected by the max player
um and here we're using helender
distance which is this like information
theoretic Divergence
um but you can think of KL if this is
more familiar to you the the difference
will not be important for the results
I'm presenting
but this is looking so this is saying
you know Information Gain if you want
this to be large you want to be
selecting a decision where these
two models you know have very different
distributions right this means that you
know even if I didn't necessarily make
my reward big I've kind of learned
something about which of the underlying
models it was okay
so okay that that was a kind of a
mouthful but let me just walk say this a
little more succinctly
so this is this is a min max problem
where the learner is trying to select a
distribution over decisions such that in
the face of an unknown environment they
want their regrets to be balanced by you
know Information Gain which is I think
is Pretty Natural the parameter gamma
here is just kind of modulating this
trade-off like how much do you care
about regret versus information get
okay just I know here
um what we're actually going to care
about here is the the max of this thing
over all reference models
um and again so why do we care about
this well what I'll show you now is this
leads to okay both upper and lower
bounds on regret for for decision making
problems um and I'll start with like the
lower bounds just kind of a teaser for
the lower bounds
so what you can show is that
uh
for any model class script M you know
the best regret that can be achieved by
any algorithm
is always lower bounded by the dec for
an appropriate choice of this parameter
gamma
and kind of the the short version of the
story here is you know you can use this
to recover you know like the usual lower
bounds for kind of all the standard
Bandit and like RL settings that you
might see studied in the literature up
to like let's say small poly factors and
perhaps some other small technical
caveats
um so all everything in this table these
are all just like special cases of this
General lower bound based on the dec
um and a point I really want to
emphasize here or something well that I
personally think is pretty cool is you
know this is not just recovering lower
bounds for like you know problems like
the Bandit that we know are tractable
this can also recover even things like
exponential lower bounds or like
intractability results for like uh you
know
RL problems that are known to be
intractable like where the optimal
sample complexity is exponentially large
which I think is pretty cool
yeah
yeah
you're saying
to those things yeah when you pick gamma
appropriately and I'll I'll give a
little bit more insight into how do you
pick Gamba yeah in a minute yep
um why the square
uh oh versus
oh I mean no no it's not super special
compared to like let's say like KO like
the difference between these things is
like I would say more or less for
technical reasons
and the bounds on the next page
yeah so I'm saying you can get all of
these using hellinger or KL unless you
like really care about log factors
and the connection between
yeah yeah so the full lower bound is
going to involve this thing and T in a
way that like you know where you're
training these offers
itself I'll get to this in like two
slides
okay
cool okay now before I get to that I
just want to give a teaser for the upper
bounds
so on the upper bound side there's kind
of a simple algorithmic principle
associated with the dec we call this
estimation to decisions and the way to
think about this is as like a meta
algorithm that kind of lets you lift
algorithms for supervised learning or
estimation into algorithms that can
solve the decision-making problem
so the way this is going to work is okay
we're going for capital T steps at each
time Little T
first I'm going to run some kind of like
supervised estimation or like learning
algorithm on all the data I've gathered
up to this point which is going to give
me like an estimator m-hat t for the the
underlying model so this can be any
algorithm you want but you know for
concreteness you know you can think of
like let's say like mle or like least
squares
um and once we have this estimator so
all we're going to do is
plug this into the min max problem and
the dec just as sort of the reference
model
we're going to pick the PT that solves
this min max problem
and then we're just going to sample the
decision to play from this distribution
and you know update this supervised
estimation algorithm with the the new
data point we collect by doing this
the show for this strategy is
it's going to make it so that your
regret is controlled by this DEC
and you know some terms it's going to
reflect how well are you doing at
estimation
um more precisely we're going to Define
s hell of T this is going to be just the
cumulative helender distance overall
rounds let's say little one or t equals
one through T of the hell injured
distance between the estimator we had at
Ram T and the true model M Star on the
particular Pi T we encounter
and so what this theorem says is if we
run e2d with scaled gamma a regret is
bounded by DEC at scale gamma times t
plus gamma times this this estimation
error
um and a point I want to emphasize here
is okay so this estimation you know this
is kind of like a sequential problem
where we're we're you know trying to do
estimation on data that's collected
adaptively based on the decisions our
algorithm selects but this is actually
something you can like provably control
like you can provably get sublinear
bounds on this using tools for online
learning or like sequential prediction
right so the point here is you know you
if you just kind of use standard online
learning tools you can get balance on
this Helen distance you know that
reflects just like the intrinsic kind of
statistical capacity of this class
script out so for example you know if I
have a finite class I can get like log
number of models if I have a parametric
class I can get something like dimension
uh to make to interpret this bound
though it's actually going to be helpful
to look at this again side by side with
a more precise version of the lower
bound
so this look this is going to be the
main lower bound and this is going to
say
okay on you know under appropriate
technical conditions
for any model class script M the best
regret that can be achieved by any
algorithm is going to be lower bounded
by the Min of two quantities
um one is this DEC at scale gamma times
T the other is gamma and then you're
taking the max over gamma
so you know intuitively this is going to
say
uh you know if the dec is large you
regret has to be large
but the cool thing here is if you run a
slightly more refined version of this
e2d algorithm you know you can get a
regret amount that matches this up to
the dependence on this helinger
estimation error so this is saying like
you know up to whatever the estimation
rate for your class is you're getting
these upper lower bounds that kind of
quantitatively match okay and let me
finally give an example to get a sensor
like the scaling here we're going to go
through many more of these in a minute
if we look at something like say the
multi-armed Bandit with a actions
we'll be able to show that the dec at
scale gamma is like a over gamma
you plug this into this lower bound you
get okay Min of a t over gamma and gamma
the right choice of gamma here is going
to balance these quantities and this is
going to give you root a t as lower
bound you know which is like the usual
Minimax rate for this problem
and this like I said we'll see more
examples but this sort of scaling where
you have like
uh some notion of complexity over gamma
this is like very common so yeah
um yeah I'm not being precise about this
so this is going to be
okay I can go into more detail about
this offline but this is going to be
basically DC for like a ball around M
Bar where the ball depends on
some parameter Epsilon gamma which
depends on gamma
um
it's a little more technical
I have some bonus slides we can go over
if there's interest in this after yeah
um this is not something that
really like matters for any of the
standard problems you would look at this
is kind of only something that matters
for what I would call like edge cases
um
now let me zoom out for a minute before
I get to more examples so kind of the
point here is because you have these
like you know upper and lower bounds
which are matching up to this estimation
error you can actually really get from
this like a characterization for like
learnability so when is learning
possible at all
um and this is going to say like okay if
you know under appropriate conditions
you can have sublinear regret if and
only if this decays polynomially as a
function of gamma and that's why we say
this is necessary and sufficient
um let me make some technical remarks
before I move on okay so first of all
okay to answer this question of like why
hell injury distance yeah so this is not
super important compared to other like
information theoretic divergences as
long as you make like pretty mild
assumptions on like the densities like
that they're bounded above you know you
can get essentially the same results up
to like log P factors the alinger just
kind of is the choice to make that uh
that makes the upper and lower bounds
kind of as clean as possible
simultaneously that's the way I would
describe this okay
um and yeah let me also just give a
tactical disclaimer here and say you
know I really only presented informal
results so far you know there are
different gaps between the upper and
lower bounds depending on exactly what
you assume and uh yeah happy to say more
about this online
are all fun
okay
let me uh zoom out and
just give a couple like conceptual
takeaways here
so first of all
you know one thing that I find exciting
about this is it really kind of gives a
way of like kind of what I would
describe as Bridging the Gap between
like learning and decision making so the
point is like we have you know
supervised learning which is just like
seemingly passive problem and then we
have decision making which is this very
like sequential and active problem but
this is saying as long as you can do
this estimation part well like as long
as you can do learning well you really
can like lift this into algorithms that
solve decision making and this really
gives you a tool that allows you to
focus on you know really more like
modeling and estimation when you're
faced with new domains rather than
algorithm design
okay this the other takeaway I want to
mention here is a connection to kind of
classical results in statistical
estimation and like lacom Theory
so if you're coming from the stat side
you might be familiar with this notion
of like modulus of continuity in
statistical estimation
this is a uh complexity measure that was
introduced by Donahoe and Lou in the 80s
for like non-parametric estimation which
is just looking at this problem where I
get a bunch of IID examples from some
distribution and I want to estimate some
kind of like functional of this
distribution
um so so and I'll just show this modulus
of continuity right here so here for
this setting okay I've kind of written
it in the same language as you know this
General decision making setting to
emphasize the similarities here models
are just going to be like you know
distributions over samples like
everything is IID
FM is the functional we want to estimate
and this is just saying you know if we
look at the hellinger ball around some
reference model like what's the biggest
error in the value of functionals
so Madonna who showed is that this lower
bounds the optimal risk for any
non-parametric estimation problem it
also gives upper bounds under like you
know various technical assumptions and
the point here is you know we really
think of the dec as giving like the
decision uh making analog of this
complexity measure and kind of a way of
lifting this kind of you know
like statistical estimation lacom
Viewpoint to General decision making
settings
um but the difference and like what
really makes
sort of the decision-making version
challenging is like because everything
is active now
you know this is why we have like a min
max problem rather than just a Max
problem this is one way of saying it
um yeah and actually just while we're on
this topic
I'll just briefly mention there's a
couple other complexity measures you may
have seen before more on the decision
making side that also kind of look at
different trade-offs between regret and
information
um
I'll just say you can check out the
paper if you want to understand more
about like how you can relate these to
the dec or when when you can and cannot
um let's see are there any questions
before I move on
[Music]
they probably have not catches
yeah that's exactly right this is the
the smartest upon annuity it's not
really capturing exploration all this
really capturing is like suppose I've
done estimation well
what is the most that I can like mess up
like I've estimated the model as well as
I can
I have some sort of uncertainty set that
remains given that I've done this so
like in the worst thing it's just like
what's the worst I can screw up it's
probably getting the second term
they create this because not quite it's
it's it's it's closer to the first term
okay yeah that's what I'm confused about
but the person the first term
right so the the difference is like what
are you estimating so the point is in
this General functional estimation
setting
so the second term is how well do you
underestimate the underlying
distribution and then the first here is
capturing like you don't actually care
about estimating the underlying
distribution you care about estimating
some function of it so this is capturing
you know what if what is the air you pay
in going from estimating the
distribution to estimating this
functional that's kind of why they call
it the modulus of continuity it's kind
of trying to capture how continuous is
this functional with respect to the
estimation error
um
yeah more or less
okay cool yeah so for the last part of
the talk I just want to go through a
bunch of different examples and just
give a sense to like how does the CEC
behave how do these bads behave when we
instantiate it right and like what do
the like minimizers like what are the
distributions that solve this Minimax
problem actually look like
um and so we'll go through a few
different types of examples the first
start gonna capture just you know how
does this thing adapt to different
structure in the reward function
then we're going to go through an
example that's a bit more information
theoretic in nature and then we'll kind
of bring observations into the picture
and look at tabular RL
um and to the extent that there's time
after that I'll try to give a sense for
what this looks like when we go to more
General RL settings as well
okay so for the first example I'll come
back to the multi-armed Bandit problem
right just finite set of actions
and for this problem I'm displaying the
full DEC here but actually what you can
do is
simplify this to a kind of a variant of
the dec where you just replace helinger
Distance by square distance between the
means these are actually equivalent for
this setting
um and the intuition is just that like
okay if I don't really assume anything
about the noise then in the worst case
the max player here can just pick like
white noise which makes everything other
than the means like uninformative
okay so as I mentioned before you know
you can show a bound on the dec that
looks like a over gamma here this gives
like a root a t lower bound
but what I want to do is kind of give a
sense for like how do we actually get
this well how do we bound the dec by a
over gamma for this setting
um and there's two strategies we'll look
at
so the first strategy is what's called
inverse Gap weighting
this is going to be like an explicit
distribution P that kind of solves this
Minimax problem and what this looks like
is okay given that I have this reference
model M Bar this parameter of gamma I'm
going to assign each uh decision Pi a
probability that's inversely
proportional to the gap between sort of
the optimal decisions reward and you
know this decision pie is own reward
under this estimated model M Bar
um this Gap is gonna okay so first of
all just say Okay so the probability is
inversely proportional to the Gap that's
why we call this inverse Gap weighting
um but this is going to be scaled by the
parameter gamma and then we're going to
pick a normalization constant Lambda
that makes this thing sum to one
so you can show that this thing exactly
minimizes the dec I showed on the
previous page this is like a this is a
pretty easy calculation this is just you
know you
you pull out the lagrangea multipliers
and turn the crank
um and this is going to lead to an a
over gamma bound and kind of the
intuition here is like okay if I take
gamma to zero this just becomes the
uniform distribution
um if I take gamma to Infinity
this just puts all its mass on this like
greedy decision
um but in general it's going to kind of
adaptively you know interpolate between
exploring and exploiting in a way that
depends on the estimated Rewards
um at one point I want to emphasize here
is like you know I think that intuition
is pretty clear but like the specific
structure of the distribution here
um you know it's very is pretty
important like you know trying to do
similar things with like say soft Max is
not going to work like the the kind of
key thing here is this distribution is
really kind of like heavy tailed in a
sense
okay that's one approach the other
approach we can look at is to appeal to
uh Bayesian methods and okay when I say
this you might say like well okay how do
we do that like I've been only working
in a frequented setting up until this
point but the idea is there's a Bayesian
counterpart of this DEC that we can show
is equivalent to the original one using
the Minimax theorem so the idea is you
can move from a Max over models here to
a Max over distributions over models
that makes this thing like bilinear in p
and this model distribution mu so you
can apply the Minimax theorem to make
the max player go first
and the interpretation here is now
the max player is picking like a prior
over models and the Min player is able
to choose their decision distribution
with knowledge of this prior so they're
trying to make this inequality hold in
expectation under the model being drawn
from the prior
um and so once you have this this
Bayesian version of the dec you know you
can appeal to kind of natural Bayesian
algorithms like say you know posterior
sampling or like probability matching
right so posterior sampling
in this context will just be the
strategy where we take P to be the
distribution induced by sampling a model
from the prior and like playing the
optimal decision for this model I mean
you can show this also leads to a bound
of like a over gamma on the dec here
um so I think I think it's a pretty cool
connection
um and sort of the point I want to
mention here is okay like why did I why
did I show these two approaches
both of these turn out to be very useful
in you know analyzing this thing like
when we go pretty far beyond
you know just the Bandit setting so even
to like RL settings so these are good
tools to have in your toolbox
okay I'll go to another example here
so this is just going to be full
information online learning
this is going to be a setting just like
Bandits we have a finite decision set
um but now we're going to see an
observation which will just be rewards
for all of the possible decisions we
could have selected right so this
there's no more Bandit feedback we get
to see everyone's reward
so if you compute the dec in this
setting it still is going to have some
kind of like one over gamma scaling but
there's not going to be any dependence
on a
the number of actions
um so this will just lead to like a root
T lower bound and this is pretty natural
right like as soon as you get to see all
the rewards you know sort of the the
distance between the different models
you look at this this no longer depends
on what distribution or what decision
you pick so you don't need to explore at
all
okay now uh yeah
for the full information setting yeah
instantiate your algorithm you have this
algorithm right it's a good reduction to
supervisor oh yeah so could you explain
what that algorithm is doing oh yeah I
mean first for full information learning
this will sort of be like the most
trivial version of this whole thing
right it's just going to be at each time
do the estimation
okay so run some supervised estimation
algorithm get an estimator
compute the optimal decision for this
estimator like what what decision you
know maximizes rewards under my
estimated model and just play this right
so like this is just 3D
don't we know that doesn't
work well no
no for full information this works just
to be fair this is like a stochastic
full information setting right it's not
like uh I'm not doing adversarial uh
Bandits right so because it's stochastic
yeah
okay
which is kind of in between Bandits and
full information and this is just to
come back to uh you know structured
Bandits where we're doing Bandits with a
potentially large decision space but you
know assuming
you know different structure like
linearity on the rewards so if you do
linear rewards you can show the dec
scales as like d over gamma where D is
like the dimension of the action space
or feature Dimension this is going to
lead to a root DT lower bound
um and the way you prove this is using
you know very similar tools to what I
showed for the Bandit case you just kind
of combine this with like uh sort of a
notion of like well chosen bases for
exploration yeah but just to go back to
the full information yeah so this isn't
a new Max I think right otherwise you
can get much much lower better bonds I
mean since dependency yeah yeah
everything in the song is Minimax
um so one point I want to mention here
about the structured Bandits is you know
this is another example where this DEC
is growing at something like you know
some notion of like effective dimension
for the problem over gamma I mean you've
seen this in a lot of settings but in
general you're not going to be see this
behavior for problems where like the
optimal weights are worse than routine
so for example if we go back to like lip
[ __ ] spandex which is this
non-parametric setting here you can show
the dec okay roughly grows as like one
over gamma to the one over D so this is
getting slower
as D grows and this leads to a lower
bound under regret that looks like T to
the D plus one over D plus two okay so
that's like the optimal rate but yeah
this is getting you know worse and worse
and worse as you take DB
it's a non-parametric problem
okay so for those examples only reward
mattered let's look at a very simple
example where like say properties like
the noise will matter this will kind of
illustrate why you would need like
something like an information theoretic
Divergence if you want to work with
General problems
so let's look at a bandit type setting
where we've got a actions but now the
way I'm going to set up the models in my
class is to say okay if I pick the
optimal action for a given model so each
model will only have one optimal action
but if I pick the optimal action I see a
reward that's like Bernoulli with mean
one half plus Epsilon so a little more
than a half
if I pick a sub-optimal action I get
gaussian with reward one half
so this is a very easy problem this is
easier than a regular Bandit problem
because you know
if I pick the optimal decision I'm going
to see either 0 or 1 is the reward like
almost surely and if I pick a
self-optimal action which has gassing
rewards I will not see reward zero or
one almost surely so all I need to do is
like do a single pass over the arms and
you know commit to the arm for which I
see either zero or one as the reward
right so this is a kind of silly problem
but like
you know if you if you want to be able
to capture General problems you do need
to be able to kind of handle this type
of structure
um but what you can show here is yeah so
the dec is actually going to have
threshold Behavior so it's going to be
like constant if gamma is smaller than
the number of actions it's going to go
to zero when gamma is bigger this is
just going to lead to a lower amount of
regret that scales as like a so there's
no real T dependence and you know this
just reflects the fact that you can do
this kind of silly strategy I just
described
okay and the point I want to emphasize
here is like yeah the the choice of an
information theoretic Divergence is
important so like hellinger or KL you
know can both instantly tell the
difference between like Bernoulli and
gaussian if you have just uh you know
squared error between the uh the the
rewards this cannot tell the difference
if you have squared error this looks
like a regular Bandit problem
um and a point that I think is is good
to emphasize here is you know
you can take this idea of like problems
or the noise and codes information like
very far so you can think about like
Bandit problems that have gaussian
rewards but actually if I go like a
hundred bits down into like the binary
representation for the reward I've gone
and encoded some like arbitrary piece of
like side information which like doesn't
really change the reward functions at
all but like again if you know this in
advance this is something you can take
advantage of so you can kind of use this
to encode arbitrary observations
and just to tie this back to the
beginning like the point the reason why
we work in this model where you
explicitly get observations you know is
just to make this explicit because this
is it's useful to be able to handle
observations
um now so with that in mind yeah let's
go to the canonical example where these
matter which is tabular RL
so just to recap we're going to be
looking at a model class where each of
these models is an mdp with Horizon H
we've got finite States in actions so s
States today actions Pi is just a set of
like policies that act on the mdp and
the observations are just like
trajectories that we get by executing
these policies
so on the lower bound side you can show
that the dec for this setting grows as
like HSA over gamma so just like you
know if I'm in this unstructured RL
setting you know just these features
like the time Horizon the number of
states the number of actions you know
these are kind of reflecting the
complexity this gives you a root hsat
lower bound
on the upper bound side you can show
similar upper bounds although with worse
dependence on H using a couple of
different strategies
um one is kind of an extension of this
inverse Gap weighting idea that we call
a policy cover inverse Gap weighting
um and the other is
yeah you know to kind of appeal to the
Bayesian counterpart of the DC and apply
posterior sampling so these both give
like poly h-10's essay over gamma
and just like
this is kind of a trivial observation
but just a point I want to mention here
is you know incorporating the
observations in this setting is critical
right so like if I do RL but I only see
rewards and no trajectories you know you
do need to pay like for exponential in
the Horizon like this is not a tractable
problem so you really need to be able to
see the trajectories to do credit
assignments
um okay and I'll just say a little tiny
bit more about this policy cover inverse
Gap weighting strategy because
well it just gives us a kind of sense
for like how you can take this inverse
Gap weighting technique to you know
richer decision making problems Beyond
Bandits
and the the idea will be to you know
basically do the same strategy as I did
for Bandits in policy space
the challenge is just like you know if I
try to naively do this for every single
policy like naively do this Gap inverse
Gap weighting for every single policy
this will have very bad sample
complexity because it doesn't really
take advantage of the fact that you can
like share information between policies
and there's a lot of policies so the
idea will be instead we'll do it to a
small set of Representative policies
and that's going to look like the
following
so again
let's fix the the reference model M Bar
this is going to be an mdp and this
parameter gamma
and for each shsa Tuple we're going to
compute uh kind of what we'll call
something like a homing policy Pi HSA
this is going to be a policy that
maximizes the ratio of two terms so what
is the probability that we like hit
State s and action a at step H that's
where the HSA come in
um and then on the denominator we're
going to have just the the
sub-optimality of this policy in the
reference model so this is trying to
trying to balance you know hitting
states that you care about but not
making your regret too big while you do
this
well you get your policy cover is just
to compute this homing policy for every
HSA put these all together
um it also put just like the greedy
policy in this set
once you have this policy cover you just
do the same strategy for Bandits but
only to the policies in the policy cover
and that's it
so kind of the key ideas here are yeah
you know this is this is balancing like
exploration or like covering the MVP by
you know considering this hitting
probability in the numerator but it's
also making sure we're you know we're
not visiting states that just have like
very bad reward right which is not good
for regret
um and the the real subtlety here is
just like
you know what we really care about is
covering on like the true mdpm star and
not on mbar
but
using kind of change of measure type
arguments you can show that like you
know when you run this strategy like one
of two things happens one is that like
you know M star and M Bar behave
similarly in which case this does give
good coverage the other case is they
don't behave similarly but that means
your Information Gain must be big which
is also good
we're just about at the end I'm going to
give a very quick taste for what happens
in more General RL settings
so you know when I talk about more
General RL settings like going Beyond
tabular
you know really what we have in mind is
like handling large State spaces and you
know this this entails you know using
function approximation and modeling
in a way that will allow us to like kind
of generalize or extrapolate across you
know States we might not have seen
before
and there's a few different ways that
you can apply the idea of modeling in
the setting right so one idea is just to
explicitly use what people usually call
model based methods and this just refers
to methods where script m is like
directly parameterizing the transition
Dynamics so if you look at like say like
linear systems like the lqr problem this
just means like m is parameterizing like
what are the transition matrices like
what are the system matrices
those are kind of model based methods
and you can also look at value-based
methods so for value-based methods
there's not usually an explicit model
class
instead you have something like a value
function class which I'm calling script
queue here which is just trying to model
the Q functions for in your MVP right so
these functions that say if I'm in state
s and take action a and then run this
policy like what's the expected return
um so yeah so for these settings I'm
usually just modeling the key functions
but you can still like apply the results
we have in these settings by just
working with an induced model class and
this is just going to be the set of all
mdps that are like consistent with your
Q function class in the sense that like
you know maybe their their Q star
functions are contained in this class
maybe like all Q functions are contained
into the glass that depends you can do
either
so you know there's many many examples
of both of these you know approaches you
know this is a pretty uh I would say
active area of research right now
um and there's also a bunch of kind of
like General Notions of like problem
complexity or like structural complexity
they kind of give sufficient conditions
they kind of try to Encompass all these
different individual settings that we
know are tractable so like you may have
seen Bell and rank before this is a very
famous One
um and so what you can show is that for
all of these
you can use these to bound the dec so if
you look at Bellman rank for example you
know you get something like DEC scales
as Bellman rank over gamma
that's cool
um one caveat here is uh this does not
always lead to end-to-end guarantees
right now because the estimation
complexity can actually be quite large
for some of these settings so this is
this is an interesting future question
um but so that's like upper bounds and
I'll just give a taste
I'd say famous line of work
um from like Chava's group that shows
that you know if you try to do like RL
with linear function approximation and
you're not careful about how you set
this up you can get say like exponential
example complexity which is not good
um and you can recover these lower
bounds through the dec
foreign
so I'm actually just at the end now so
I'm going to go ahead and summarize so
okay we saw in this DC this complexity
measure this is necessary and sufficient
for low regrets but yeah personally what
I find exciting is you know this really
gives kind of something like a unified
handle that you can use to study
algorithm design
when you encounter new settings
um in terms of future directions
I think there's a lot of very
interesting ones
um one I'll just mention first is on the
Practical side
so if you specialize this all to the
case of like Horizon one so like
contextual Bandits
we've actually already seen that the
algorithms that come out of this
framework are like very practical and
even have like state-of-the-art
performance and I'm just giving a teaser
here but like uh yeah these are actually
already in this like VW library for kind
of online and like interactive machine
learning so you know if you want to like
down run these and try them out it's
very easy to get sort of get this
started
um but I think when we go beyond Horizon
one uh there's room for a lot of
Investigation in terms of understanding
like how can we get
you know algorithms for RL that really
like work in the real world right and
this is a combination of I think well
algorithm design but also figuring out
what kinds of models uh work well
okay and I'll just say a little bit more
broadly you know the real the real kind
of broader research program here is just
trying to like build foundations for
these these data-driven decision-making
settings they kind of give us some kind
of understanding that parallels what we
have for you know these more classical
settings like supervised learning or
estimation
um and this really is not just limited
to the setting I went over in the talk
today so I think there's you know a huge
amount of opportunity here in like
understanding how can we do similar
things for like you know learning with
log data learning in like multi-agent
settings and these are questions I'm
thinking about a lot right now
and of course there's many open uh
technical questions with people like
this sort of thing so happy to chat
about those more offline but I'll I'll
stop there and take questions
yes Kevin
uh seems like the the dec is it kind of
comes down to like parameter accounting
at least at a very very high level but
like the estimation part we're like
looking into like the union down type
stuff I should estimate that yeah upper
bound right yes we've gotten any closer
showing that in the lower bound
um
I would say no but I also haven't been
trying that hard
um
yeah so so this is an interesting this
is an interesting problem like in the
sense of like understanding what is the
minimal notion of estimation you have to
do in some sense and what's subtle is
like
if you want to get the tightest possible
results you cannot fully like decouple
these things like there are some
problems where the estimation error uh
should not be there in the upper bound
and you can just get rid of it there are
other problems where it should be there
um and you know so the question is how
do you make it appear in the lower
bounds right so like it you know it's
not just a question of like
yeah like I said it can't be fully
decoupled from the decision-making part
and I think that's really interesting in
some sense like
the key question here to me is like
what is like the kind of the minimal
sort of like sufficient statistic that
you actually have to estimate for a
given model class like it seems like any
model class should like induce a
sort of
fundamental notion of distance that's
like tailored to the model class so like
if you do Bandits like something that
automatically pops out of this is like
you really don't care about estimating
the distribution you just care about
estimating the means but like that's
kind of like an ad hoc calculation that
you can do
I don't know if uh sort of like
systematic way of deducing like what is
the right notion of a sufficient
statistic or a general problem but this
is like very much related to your
question I think it's super interesting
oh yes so I guess
they know often that we can get better
than Facebook yeah
so we know that we can get
non-stationary yes yes
okay so I'll do the second one first so
one natural Berry you can do for this is
like the adversarial setting so imagine
a setting where instead of there being
like a fixed underlying model an
adversary chooses a model class in your
model class at each time step you know
this is something that like encompasses
like you know
adversarial band of problems adversarial
linear Bandit problems adversarial like
data complex optimization whatever you
want so we've actually already extended
this stuff to that setting the
algorithms are completely different
but the serve guarantee you get is same
sort of Upper and Lower bounds but
rather than DEC for the original class
you pay for the dec of the convex Hull
of the model class so like the gap
between stochastic and adversarial is
like how does your class behave under
like convexification so okay that paper
is online it's called like on the
complexity of adversarial decision
making if people want to Google it
um yeah for instance dependent this is a
very interesting question
uh which Andrew and I have been working
on for the last two months so hopefully
uh there should be
the results are like quite
it's quite subtle compared to the
Minimax case but um yeah we we've made
some pretty good progress on this I
think so okay I guess keep an eye out
for okay
oh yeah so your technician is
it seems like it yeah
right um
so usually the strategy
or I'll let you say it's like in all
cases the strategy being used to achieve
the minimum
um depends on the particular M Bar you
look at but yeah you you like usually
the way you bound the DC is just by like
you know figuring out about it for the
fixed reference level and then just like
taking the max over all these things
yeah
I'm saying that for the bomb like you
don't even need the max you're able to
make it
you mean for M bars that are like not
necessarily in the class or you know
yeah
it looks like a big sandwich I guess
I'll just say like it's not clear to me
why these are different if you're
thinking about like upper bounds right
like I'm just saying like saying that
this thing is upper bounded uniformly
for all models and bar is kind of the
same as oh I see you sink to the lower
rounds yeah
um
yeah so usually for the lower bounds you
know you pick like M Bar to be I would
say kind of like an uninformative model
like for like Bandits or something you
take it to be like just like flat
um
but yeah it notice through the lower
bounds I mean
usually these are yeah usually they're
these are realized for like reasonable
looking M bars but like
all right sounds good
yeah the posters
was that for uh
well so
so it's for the Beijing encounter part
of the dec
Ade it's not for like the it's not for
like Bayesian regret yeah so the point
is I can go back to this real quick
actually
um so yeah the the point is
foreign
right so the point is you can show the
posterior sampling gives a bound of a
over gamma on this thing like uniformly
for all choices of prior
you could just anything
uh yeah
please meet students
um I mean it's
it's not important if it has support on
llm I mean if it has support on a
smaller set of actions okay you'll get a
smaller bound to the neighbor again
if your prior doesn't have support on
the model that you that to model then
you will never get
um
this is a setting this is like a sort of
a setting so so again like this is this
is not like looking at basic regret this
is literally just like a
this is just an analysis tool right so
I'm just saying this is a major like
this the dec is like a one-step game
this is like a beige encounter part of
this one step game but I'm saying this
is a setting where like you have like a
well-specified prior in some sense right
like the max player picks this View and
like the kind of true model as far as
this expression is concerned is like
drawn from this body it's
non-constructed yeah yeah but yeah this
is an important Point here right this is
like non-constructed in the sense that
like this is just a way of proving that
this thing is bounded it's like the use
of Minimax theorem yeah exactly exactly
yeah yeah I mean in a formal sense that
is a special case yeah yeah
um are there any other questions
yeah thanks a lot